the final stage is the rice for the
briyani
first we clean and part ball basmati
rice so the rice is good that a bag of
sort of aromatic spices so it's like a
bouquet garni
now I'm learning the technique known as
dumb cooking the rice is placed in a
special pan and saffron a salad then the
pan is sealed with pastry and the rice
is left to steam but one small mistake
can mean disaster I know stuff on
wrapper Oh
time to put on the pastry seal but it's
not happening quick enough for empty
airs a couple of laughs a couple oh hey
what's wrong
okay who's pissed him off was that I
don't know sounds like we're only
getting a gallon I do huh no I love me
he's gonna let rip at me in a minute huh
I feel like I gotta gather we're in
situations like this you keep your mouth
shut and finish the job quickly the
whole star behind dumbbell cooking is
keeping all the flavors locked in so see
me with the pastry on the outside is
that little sort of work of magic so how
long for that now Danny okay cool
are they gonna take a 25 minutes